LESTER CHEN: So
my name is Lester.
I'll be talking about the
hyper growth of mobile gaming
on YouTube.
So when people
have conversations
around mobile gaming, they often
talk about the amount of users,
the amount of revenue generated.
But rarely do to talk
about the amount of content
that's actually
consumed on video.
So on YouTube,
mobile gaming content
comprises around
1.6 billion hours
watched in last year, 2016.
Now it's from some of
these games mentioned here,
but many others, some of
which you guys developed.
Now this is huge mainly because
in 2015 mobile gaming really
wasn't a category that we
were paying attention to.
With the advent of hardware,
better software, better
graphics engines, it's
become more available
for people to actually
want to go on YouTube
and watch more robust
content from these games.
So in comparison to all
the rest of the gaming
corpus on YouTube--
that's Call of Duty, League of
Legends, any MOBAs, Minecraft--
mobile gaming as a
category-- these games--
actually grew at a
clip of around 110%,
which is what we
consider hyper growth.
In July, we saw a huge spike in
hours consumed with Pokemon Go,
obviously, being released.
But even after the months
following Pokemon Go,
we saw huge uplift in
mobile game consumption.
This is mainly aided by games
such as Clash Royale, Pokemon
Go, and two indie titles--
slither.io and Agar.io.
We think that as far
as Clash Royale goes,
Supercell has done a great
job releasing content
as far as cart updates,
balance and patch notes, which
makes the game really
sticky for audiences
and the broadcasters
of this game company
to really produce more and more
content for their audience.
With the case of
Pokemon Go, the game
was just so explosive
with so many millions
of registered users.
Obviously, it is going to
create a desire from audiences
to want to watch, whether that's
where the next Poke Stop is
or someone falling into a
lake, tripping over something,
or whatever have you.
And with slither.io
and agar.io, these
are both very simplistic
games with high replayability.
You can just pick
it up and play.
I think if any of you guys
have seen "House of Cards,"
even Kevin Spacey in
that game was playing it.
So the concept there was kind
of a vehicle through which
creators on YouTube could
create their commentary
and do game play over.
So you can't talk
about all the games
without also talking
about the creators.
Last year, these
are just a handful
of the creators who are
publishing mobile gaming
content exclusively
on their channels.
There's over 350
more of these guys
just like the ones you see here.
But combined, the
audience that they have
is around 20 million
total subscribers.
So the question really is--
now setting the stage of
how big mobile gaming is--
how do you really
use all these content
to influence game decisions?
And vice versa, how
can game decisions
really help spur content
creation on a video platform?
So in the case of YouTube,
this is our first Foray.
We created an event called the
King's Cup, which we partnered
with Supercell and
Google Play to create
a really unique tournament.
We used the top 8 live
streamers and content creators
of Clash Royale and got them
to a one day Los Angeles-based
tournament location where
we're going to live stream
the whole tournament.
Now, that's simple.
It's just creating a live event.
It's a very competitive
game, of course.
That's going to be
pretty attractive.
But we also parroted
with an in-game feature--
and this is the
first time Supercell
had released an in-game heavily
discounted bundle of discounted
chests and gems as well as
an in-game challenge mode.
I think since now, they've
released three or four
other game challenge modes,
but this was the first one.
And this is really
influenced by the fact
that we were producing
and executing
a live event that was big
enough with as many creators
as they have that
really pushed them
to create an in-game solution.
So obviously, the chests and
discounts was an awesome offer,
but within the King's
Cup Challenge itself,
players at home during
the live stream event
could play with
decks pre-selected
from the top gamers,
the top YouTubers,
and the top pro players.
So they kind of got to
have a shared experience.
And since this event
was so big, there's
also a sense of scarcity, right?
Where people want to tune in
and watch this high profile
event, and also at
home feel like they
are part of the experience.
And when they're seeing
the best decks being played
at this tournament, they're
also incentivized to, of course,
buy cards and buy
chests to play more.
So this is a concept we
kind of played around with.
We really had no idea how
this was going to do--
just kind of producing and
executing a concept like this.
But at the end, we had
around 63,000 people
watching the live event--
over eight and a half,
nine million views
generated on the video itself.
We had Korean and English feeds.
And the event was kind of an
in-person one day event where
we invited--
it was the most bizarre--
call it e-sports--
competitive event
where there was 400
people in a room
all heads down, quiet
for about four hours,
just grinding out
Clash Royale game play.
I've been to a lot
of gaming events
and that is by far the
most eerie/surreal one.
But it was amazing seeing
so many people connected
playing a mobile game in a
physical location in one place.
Imagine if all of you guys
were all on your phones
right now competing
against one another.
It was a really
unique experience.
On the left, we basically
drummed up a lot of excitement
by sending the creators special
Clash Royale chests, which
the top eight creators
kind of, Willy Wonka style,
got invited to this
tournament or they came.
And these guys were kind
of like the Iron Chegs
of the whole broadcast, where
the 300 people kind of had
to face off in order to
play against these guys
in the finale.
So in the end, there
was one winner.
It was a very unique
idea that we just
want to prove out a concept.
As far as YouTube
gaming goes, we
saw huge amount of uplift of
people downloading the app
and activating with
YouTube Gaming.
For the publisher as
well as Google Play,
we saw a huge multiplier
on day-of revenues.
And in total, we created
a big experience--
a high profile
unique experience--
where almost 8.5
million people tuned in.
So kind of the recipe for
success that we learned
she was really
using influencers.
I'm sure none of you guys are
new to leveraging influencers.
But really, tying that to kind
of a triangle where you create
a live opportunity where
there's a high profile event--
where it's so exciting and
everyone wants to watch this
one event--
and also tie that to a live
ops opportunity where people--
the millions of registered users
at home-- can also participate.
Whether it's purchasing or
downloading in-game content
and also having an ability
to play a challenge mode,
much like what they can
see on the YouTube content.
It really created
an ecosystem where
it was really sticky
and really attractive
to both audiences, Google
Play, and the game publishers.
So-- up next is Dan.
Thank you so much for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]